من ياتيهم بعضهم لفظ انفاسه الاخيره على
مداخل المشافي واخرون على ايديهم على وقت
يجيبوا لي الطفل فانا عم باخذه فعم
بيقولوا لي عايش عايش فبدي
بكون انفاسه الاخيره يعني
لانه انا فقدت رفيقتي هون راحت الضحايا
كانت ممرضه معنا جابوا لنا رئيس المشفى
فنحن عرفناه استشهد الله يرحمه فتركناه
والتفتنا لغيره
الله يرحمه ففي عالم لسه لسا عايشه لسا
بالديانا فنحن رحنا لهناك الحزن المؤجل
رافق صرخه الخذلان فالاخيره باتت مالوفه
في سوريا وسقلتها حرب ممتده منذ 12 عاما
لتكمل عليها كارثه راح ضحيتها الالاف في
كل زاويه منها هناك من يبكي الفقد ويقول
لو كان هناك امكانيات او مساعدات لربما من
ابكيه ظل موجودا الارض خذلتنا
الحرب خزنتنا
كل الدنيا خذلتنا ما حدا اجا انقذ كان
الدفاع المدني بالخط الاول
[موسيقى]
ما حدا اجانا من برا فخلاص وقف الصوت
الاصوات اللي نزلنا نسمعه تحت الانقاذ
ساعتين ثلاثه كان ما كان